hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we will be taking a
deep dive
into the research on intermittent
fasting so feel free to pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with
current or previous experiences with
disordered eating
we are going to be talking about
calories and macros so
please feel free to skip this video if
that's not supportive to your journey
also don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out on a video
so before we get too far into it let's
start with a quick refresher on what
intermittent fasting
actually is basically intermittent
fasting involves
abstaining from any caloric food or
beverage
for a designated period of time now
there are three main types of
intermittent fasting
which will vary in terms of the length
and frequency of the fast
for example alternate day fasting
involves
alternating between feeding days and
fasting days
so you might eat normally on monday
fast tuesday eat again wednesday etc
whole day fasting otherwise known as the
5-2 method
involves eating normally for five days
of the week
and fasting or consuming very minimal
calories for
one to two days lastly there's the most
common version
called time restricted fasting also
known
as the 16-8 method which typically
involves a
16-hour fast and an eight-hour eating
window
all right with that out of the way let's
kick off our faq
starting with the first major question
what
if anything can you consume while you're
fasting
now there's no hard and fast rules when
it comes to what you can eat
during your eating window but really
like anything goes
but during a fast you are expected to
abstain from
any food or beverage with any caloric
value as this will ultimately break your
fast
so that means obviously no food but also
no bone broth alcohol coconut water milk
juice protein powder or even some
supplements like branched chain amino
acids a lot of fasters will consume
black coffee or tea but this is actually
a bit of a contested suggestion
some researchers argue that caffeine
actually alters your metabolism
and therefore breaks the fast while
others argue that because it contains no
calories
it's fair game so ultimately it really
probably depends on your intentions
and your goals with intermittent fasting
next let's talk about what
happens in the body during a fasted
state so when you fast your body is not
getting any energy from food
which will ultimately cause your blood
sugar and insulin levels to
naturally decline and insulin is often
regarded as the
fat storing hormone a concept that i'm
going to unpack
in a lot more detail in just a bit
however your body still needs fuel to
function
and it's therefore going to resort to
other forms of energy
so first the body will use up all of its
stored glucose aka
like gym which generally takes about 24
hours to deplete
after that the body begins to break down
fat stores
and use fat for energy which is
essentially what is involved when we
talk about ketosis
now with that information in mind let's
talk about some frequently asked
questions
will you lose body fat while
intermittent fasting
so proponents of intermittent fasting
suggest that one of the main benefits of
fasting
is that it can help you shed body fat
and ultimately of course
lose weight the thinking is that by
keeping our insulin levels low for
longer periods of time
we're reducing those fat storage
opportunities
and also for longer fasts we are
switching to utilize our
fat stores for fuel however this doesn't
automatically
result in body fat loss whether or not
you lose weight while intermittent
fasting
really depends on your total energy
balance
in other words what and how much you eat
as well as how much you move throughout
the day so for example
if you're spending a lot of energy
throughout your day and your intake is
low during your eating window this will
likely result in weight loss because
you're putting yourself into a caloric
deficit in contrast if you feel hungrier
during your eating window and therefore
you eat more and move
less this likely will not result in any
weight loss and
even could potentially result in weight
gain so if there's
no difference between how much you
exercise and how much you eat
but that you're simply shifting the time
when you eat
then you very well could just maintain
your weight despite doing
intermittent fasting this variability in
weight loss outcomes while intermittent
fasting
has been seen in a recent 2020 study on
time restricted fasting which showed
that
on average people do tend to lose weight
while intermittent fasting
but we also see a lot of people
maintaining their weight or gaining
weight
as well so bottom line intermittent
fasting does not automatically equate to
weight loss
just because of fat metabolism or
the reduction in insulin spikes now with
that
said this brings us to our next question
why do most people lose weight while
intermittent fasting
so the reason why we might see weight
loss while intermittent fasting
has less to do with using body fat for
energy
or keeping insulin levels low and more
to do with the fact that
people are just likely to eat less
while deliberate caloric restriction
isn't built into the diet
meaning you could theoretically eat
whatever you want
during your eating window a lot of
people just
don't fully compensate for you know
their fasted meals
during that eating window so yeah
apparently a lot of us are just not so
great at making up fully
for the meals that we skip for example
one study on
whole day fasting found that while
participants
did eat more calories than baseline
after a 36 hour fast
the extra calories were not nearly
enough
to make up for all of the calories that
they missed
during that long fast so for example if
you need
2 000 calories a day to maintain your
weight and you eat
nothing on monday but then you eat 3 000
calories on tuesday
that still would be a 1000 calorie
deficit overall that could result in
significant weight loss over time
depending on how often you were to fast
now to tie this
all together is intermittent fasting
better than continuous caloric
restriction when it comes to
losing weight so in general there's
actually
not much of a difference between
intermittent fasting and
other calorically restrictive diets when
it comes to
weight loss for example studies have
shown that when an
individual is in a caloric deficit from
intermittent fasting
or from just general calorie counting
and maintaining a deficit
they tend to lose weight at the same
rate
one 2017 study compared alternate day
fasting
and continuous caloric restriction even
though both groups
had the same weekly caloric deficit of
25 percent
the study found no difference in weight
loss
further confirming that it's really the
deficit
and not anything magical happening
metabolically
that results in that weight loss in
addition
the research suggests that the amount of
weight lost during intermittent fasting
and daily caloric restriction is
relatively the same
with one study showing that intermittent
fasting resulted in a
four to eight percent weight loss in
three weeks
and caloric restriction resulted in a
five to eight percent weight loss
so if weight loss is your goal but you
find that intermittent fasting is just
not very sustainable to you in the long
term
you won't be missing out on its
potential weight loss benefits
if you follow an alternate diet that is
just a better fit for your lifestyle
next up on the faq does intermittent
fasting reduce
insulin levels so as discussed one of
the asserted benefits
of intermittent fasting is that it keeps
levels of the fat storing hormone
insulin
lower it's often suggested that every
single time we eat
the spike in insulin can stimulate the
body to immediately
store fat but i want to elaborate
a little bit more on this idea of
insulin as
the big bad fat storing hormone
insulin's main role in the body is
actually to help our cells
absorb glucose for fuel when our glucose
stores are full
insulin will then store any excess
glucose essentially as
fat so even though insulin does play a
role in body fat storage
this is only going to occur when we
consume more
energy aka calories than what our body
actually needs
in other words any increase in body fat
has more to do with
what and how much we're eating and
whether or not we are eating beyond our
needs this goes back to what we already
discussed earlier
so for example if someone were to
consume more
food than what they actually normally
would eat during their eating window
this would cause a big spike in insulin
and may increase the likelihood that
excess glucose would be stored as body
fat
and this may likely be the case for
those individuals who experience
ravenous hunger and therefore weight
gain during intermittent fasting
i also want to point out that when it
comes to insulin spikes carbs tend to be
villainized the most as we do know that
carbs break down into glucose
which then stimulates the release of
insulin however
i want to actually clarify that protein
also stimulates insulin especially
things like
dairy beef beans and fish and
some protein foods can even actually be
more insulin stimulating
than some carbohydrate foods this speaks
to why it's recommended that you avoid
protein shakes
and bcaas during a fast so now that we
know
that body fat storage has less to do
with insulin
and more to do with how much we eat in
response to
hunger does intermittent fasting benefit
insulin sensitivity so if you're
unfamiliar with the term
insulin sensitivity it basically refers
to
how sensitive your body's cells are in
response to insulin
a higher insulin sensitivity essentially
means that your cells are able to
use glucose more effectively which will
reduce blood sugar levels
so this is definitely a positive thing
as low
insulin sensitivity otherwise known as
insulin resistance
can be a precursor to type 2 diabetes
now when it comes to the effect of
intermittent fasting on insulin
sensitivity
it seems to depend on the length of the
fast and the timing of the eating window
one 2010 study showed that a prolonged
60-hour fast resulted in lower
insulin sensitivity upon feeding meaning
that
even though blood sugar and insulin
levels were low throughout the fast
reintroducing food during the eating
window
resulted in lower rates of glucose
uptake
this is not ideal because that means
that the glucose that isn't being
efficiently absorbed
stays in the bloodstream resulting in
higher blood sugar levels which
is not good no god
no god please no ideally we want
ourselves to be
sensitive to insulin so that we can
actually
maximize the use of glucose for fuel
however keep in mind that this study
looked at a prolonged fast which
may or may not mimic the types of
intermittent fasting that
most of your favorite influencers
actually do on the other hand
another study looked at an intermittent
fasting approach where participants
consumed
one meal during a four hour eating
window
from four to eight pm this study found
that consuming
one meal per day later on in the evening
also resulted in lower insulin
sensitivity
meaning there was less glucose being
absorbed for energy
from this meal again not what we want
however
when we look at meals consumed earlier
in the day
we actually don't see the same effect
one 2018 study
looking at time restricted fasting found
that participants experienced
increased insulin sensitivity when they
consumed their meal
earlier on in the day with that said
insulin sensitivity appears to be
highest in the morning and declines
throughout the day
and this goes for everyone regardless of
whether you are intermittent fasting
or not a lot of this has to do with our
natural circadian
alignment in other words our sleep and
wake cycles
so if we can align our food intake
during daylight hours
when our insulin sensitivity is at its
peak it may actually benefit our
metabolism
and glucose response therefore
intermittent fasters
would benefit from scheduling their
eating window closer to the morning
rather than the evening and avoiding
more prolonged
fasting periods next up can a fasted
workout improve
muscle mass some proponents of
intermittent fasting have suggested that
intermittent fasting can support muscle
growth after a workout while we do have
mechanisms in the body to prevent muscle
wasting during a period of starvation or
fasting
these mechanisms don't really kick in
until around day five of a fast which
means that during short-term
intermittent fasting
muscle mass is not really being
protected
and could potentially break down in fact
the longer the fasting window the more
muscle breakdown will occur for instance
muscle breakdown is highest for
whole day fast and alternate day fasts
with time-restricted fast with you know
two to three meals a day
these are typically better able to
support muscle synthesis
assuming that of course you're eating
enough during your eating window
however a recent 2020 study suggested
that
individuals participating in time
restricted fasting
still can experience a one to five pound
loss in muscle mass
during a 12 week period if muscle
building is your goal intermittent
fasting may not be your best bet
it's also worth noting that you can't
necessarily
compensate for the increased rate of
muscle breakdown
just by consuming a really big big
protein meal
after your fast this is because the body
can only utilize a certain amount of
protein
for muscle synthesis the remainder of
which is then used for fuel
and is not stored in muscle tissue so
if your goal is muscle growth ideally
you want that protein that you consume
to be used for
muscle tissue instead of energy however
in order to achieve this
you would really want to be increasing
the number of meals and snacks consumed
per day
and eating regularly like every three to
four hours
which would unfortunately present a
conflict with
intermittent fasting this is why
traditional fitness competitor diets
have folks eating like i don't know like
a million meals
from morning tonight just second
breakfast
lunch second lunch and first dinner now
to round out this
faq on intermittent fasting let's
discuss
some of the key takeaways one
if intermittent fasting suits your
lifestyle and aligns with your natural
hunger cues
it may be able to be used somewhat
successfully
as a tool for weight loss however keep
in mind that
results may vary and it's not that much
different from
any other calorically restrictive diet
number two any body fat loss from
intermittent fasting
has less to do with low insulin levels
and using fat for fuel
and more to do with the likelihood of
being in a caloric deficit from
a restricted eating window number three
to improve insulin sensitivity
you should aim to schedule your eating
window earlier on
in the day and avoid prolonged fasts
and four most athletes whose goal is to
improve muscle mass or strength
should maybe avoid intermittent fasting
as it may increase the likelihood of
muscle breakdown
older adults and of course those who
struggle with disordered eating
should also avoid intermittent fasting
and folks that is
all that i have for you guys today if
you like this video
please be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below
on what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye